I want to pull up this tweet from Matt
taibi it's uh tweet number eight in the
Twitter files expose he says by 2020
requests from connected actors to delete
tweets were routine one executive would
write to another more to review from the
Biden team the reply would come back
handled Libs of tick tock did the
digging and found that these accounts
that were listed by the Biden
Administration as needing to be banned
were in fact suspended more so Andrew
Kerr says I've pulled web Archives of
three of these tweets all three are
homemade Hunter Biden porn and Hunter
Biden picks pulled from his laptop these
tweets don't contain any info on Hunter
Biden's business dealings just porn
can't immediately find Archives of other
of the other tweet two tweets the Biden
Administration was embarrassed about a
family member unrelated to the campaign
as far as I know and Twitter obliged in
removing negative information
this is uh here's the best part October
24th 2020. within a couple weeks of the
election the Biden Administration was in
contact with Twitter to remove damaging
information images Etc
it goes to show that the people in the
middle we were just talking about what
chance they have to know the truth ever
about anything what do you really think
about it I understand everyone here is
going to do digging and things and it's
not going to be a problem for the people
in this room but the normal person wife
husband kids goes to school maybe that's
job maybe two jobs how do you ever find
the truth if the only time you consume
the news is maybe you sit down at night
and you turn on NBC or ABC for 15
minutes you know yeah maybe they're a
little biased but I'm catching headlines
how do you explain to that person that
every single thing you were told on the
television set is a lie how do you
explain to that person that the Biden
family is actually a criminal Network by
all all appearances make it look like a
criminal Network when you look at Tony
bobolinski and others and they'll never
find out even on Twitter because like
you just pointed out anything damaging
about this family gets axed right away I
I I feel bad for so many normal
Americans who are obsessed politicos
like us because you have you live in a
world of Make-Believe and you don't even
know it you have no idea is a and and
seven eight years of it so they they say
um you know what was it the ship of
Theseus was that the uh the old story I
went to Community College you know it's
like if you have a boat and you replace
a part of it is it still the same boat
what if you dismantle the whole boat and
then yeah yeah so then then you
reconstruct the other parts and I have
two ships which one's the real ship it's
an interesting uh concept
uh I totally just lost my train of
thought I think after nine there's uh
ten that I think is also worth noting
and putting up there which I think is is
worth discussing because I do see
Washington DC sort of like Lord of the
Rings and power that uh political
parties wield against each other is that
ring that all the parties refuse to
throw away but want more of that power
and authority but number 10 reads I
don't know if you want to read it Tim or
or if I should near it it says uh by
Matt taibi both parties had access to
these tools for instance in 2020
requests from both the Trump White House
and Biden campaign were received and
honored however 11 goes on and then
explains how it was mainly Democrats
using this system but in fact uh the the
Trump Administration did use it as well
which makes you wonder who did it first
and and what kind of Pandora box was
open from here except I I don't I I
think you're you're con your framing is
incorrect the point he made in 11 is
that because most of the people who work
at Twitter are leaning towards the
Democrat Party they are the ones who are
like that was the bias so when we hear
that like Trump had the ability to flag
tweets too his campaign it's kind of
like yes of course conservatives are on
Twitter Liberals are on Twitter and when
conservatives complain they get told
shut up and when liberals complain they
say okay we'll take care of business
that's the political bias that is being
proven beyond beyond a doubt
confirmation 100 that's exactly what is
being they're being accused of yeah
obviously the Democrats had more of an
overwhelming advantage on big Tech
social media mainly because of the
connections there but also a lot of
these big tech companies understand that
the Democrats are the party that is
going to allow them to do whatever they
want to do and not regulate them or not
even put them in any kind of check or
any kind of line when it comes to
accountability and transparency here but
but it does read that the Trump
Administration the Trump White House did
do this did use these tools and they
were honored which I think is is worth
noting if they were the first ones
because if they were they they opened
the Pandora box which deserves to be
criticized in my opinion perhaps but I
just just to point out the ability to
report someone for a tweet is not
remarkable to me the the fact that
Twitter is biased and because of their
bias catered to Democrats is the
confirmation I think we're looking for I
think to kind of piggyback off your
point a little bit on that Luke is you
say it's because you know they're biased
and things like that and all that stuff
is obviously true but if I can
compliment Democrats actually here I I
think I think people with big Tech and
people in other companies other
Industries understand full well when the
Democrats will come after them if they
prove themselves to be the enemy of the
democratic party the Democrats have
proven that time and time and time again
look what they're doing with the oil
industry right now the president of the
United States of America feels totally
comfortable going on social media and
saying we're we're about to raise your
taxes if you don't pump more oil okay
that's an impeachable offense right
there you're the president of the United
States of America you're not the
dictator you can't do that but Democrats
will follow through on those whereas you
have the Low T GOP they would never
choose to punish their enemies in
Corporate America if you even have one
that attempts to do so like like there
have been some attempts in Florida to do
so you'll have half the right
immediately come out and say that's not
who we are wait guys that's not who we
are Democrats would never say that's not
who we are so it only makes sense
frankly if you're in Corporate America
to serve the Democrats because they're
they're going to punish you if you don't
and you know the losers in the
Republican Party won't ever do anything
that's that's not who we are we're
DeSantis also uh is getting a lot of
attention because of his actions against
Disney he also pulled the state out of
the BlackRock ESG social credit score
system as well a couple days ago which I
think is worth noting as well so I I do
see his popularity because he's willing
to stand up against a lot of these
bigger corporations but also these
bigger corporations naturally will
understand hey someone's threatening my
power here I better go over to the party
that we're going to fortify in power and
I think we're in a position where Mark
Zuckerberg has already donated hundreds
of millions of dollars and has four to
fight the Democrats future in this
country for the next 10 20 30 40 maybe
even 50 years I don't see the
Republicans winning because of how much
they have invested in this larger game
which they have uh you know swayed for
their own personal benefit I think both
these parties are complete trash
trying to get clout and it's a
popularity contest they get bribes from
lawyers to pass certain laws it's
disgusting the whole process is
absolutely disgusting and it's it's
destined for uh destruction and you
rolled a 100 on the 100-sided I wish it
was more positive 100 it was definitely
100 in a negative vein but this is part
of why I'm not like I do not support
what Kanye said the way he said stuff
but I support a fresh energy in politics
even if it means it's a risk of stepping
they know where you live now you're in
the White House like that's a risk but I
I can't stand by and watch it fall apart
Jesse looked confused a second we
there's a meme when you roll a 20 in
Dungeons and Dragons it means it's like
a perfect success and when you roll a
one it means a perfect failure so
whenever you know Ian says something
people will rate him in the chat as
either a one total failure or 20 total
success but he has a 100-sided die over
there so when he said both parties are
trash I said you rolled a 100 it's like
it could not be better I could not have
been more lost
I wanted to roll a 100 I just said no
man yeah you'll roll you'll roll many
ways I think you did several times but
just chime in with both parties being
trained I guess I I agree absolutely say
both parties is a little
mind-controllable
insulting trash though
I will say to what you just said Ian
which I agree with both parties trash
you're ready for something new that this
is why though this is why I believe just
allow me to go here for a second this is
why I believe we're actually heading
down a very very dark path as a country
because this is not unique for America
we are a late stage Republic you know
we've lasted about as long as a major
Empire generally lasts and then things
start to come apart as things get more
and more corrupt and things start to
fray a little bit and then the people
hunger for exactly what you just said
exactly what I I agree with you on I
want something fresh but something fresh
is almost always something bad it's
almost always something bad that sounds
good they choose to go to the guy who
will rise up and say I will change I
will I will punish these bad people I
will do this for you and that's how
Nations have consistently time and time
again ended up with some kind of
horrific dictator because the people who
are in charge suck and I'll eventually
get to the point where I'm so sick of
them I'll pick anybody who's gonna go
beat up these people and that's where I
think we're going sadly a dorsey's
involvement here is also interesting
because as my Matt Tybee points out you
know he didn't know that a lot of this
was happening I mean some people are
questioning that like is that really
possible here but the last kind of
statement by Matt taibi right now says
that quote there are multiple instances
in the files of dorsi intervening to
question suspensions and other
moderation actions for accounts across
the political Spectrum now if he was you
know questioning and intervening and
trying to to stop some of this which it
looks like he was he was absolutely
unsuccessful in doing so so was Vijaya
Gotti calling the shots here was she
really in charge here and was Dorsey
just a representative figure that
couldn't do anything or just sit on his
hands I think it's worth asking after
looking at these kind of documents what
do you guys think Tim you talk to these
people uh was was vinjaya more in charge
of Jack or Jack more capable here
there's a lot of people that said that
she was the one who was actually in
charge uh Dorsey was just a figurehead
he had left the company I think I don't
know the exact time time frame but
didn't they bring him back after like
dick Costello or whatever yeah they
brought him back to be CEO for the
second time but he wasn't really the CEO
as a lot of people said I don't think he
was either I think he was a figurehead
it's like he's the founder we had
confidence in the company so bring him
back he had very little stake in the
company at that point he had very little
control over it and he would say all of
these beautiful things that never
happened it's kind of like what Apple
did with Steve Jobs he left they
realized oh we're failing now we need
the a division again bring back the
Visionary but you know at some point
it's the owners that run the network and
I think the owners invested are vested a
lot of faith in Vijaya and basically
gave her Carpe launch to make decisions
and if she violated their wants then
they would have let her know I I kind of
disagree with that a little bit because
I I don't think they ever worry about
owning and I don't think they ever worry
about popularity the Communists have
done this very very well for a very long
time they worry about I brought it up a
little bit earlier they worry about the
choke points just go find and control
the choke points and then you control
the company that I really need to not
say her name and I'm going to screw that
up and tell you something I don't want
to say the Gotti chick she didn't she
did didn't she's not a majority opinion
like like I brought up at the beginning
we saw actually I was surprised by the
amount of pushback there was within
Twitter hey do we even have
justification for this well she didn't
care she was in the one spot where she
could be she found the one spot in the
company she could get to where she could
make sure that she could play God and
she got there and she played God they do
this all the time in Endless walks of
life Way Beyond Twitter they do it uh an
example you hear people complain all the
time now about there'll be some small
red town in Oklahoma somewhere some
small five thousand person town in
Oklahoma they're having a child drag
show and people are freaking out how's
this happen it's a 98 Republican Town
well how it happens if you ever dig into
it and I've dug into these things before
it's never the majority of the time they
don't need the majority of the town that
what they needed was one guy at the city
parks department who sought out that
position for that specific goal he found
the choke point and then he pushed it
that's how these things happen the truth
is the commies have always been better
at gov government than anyone on the
right Libertarians conservative
nationalists whatever you want to call
yourself because they live and die for
it it's their profession it's what they
it's their religion so you would you've
never been to a city council meeting
most people watching even Tim cast as
big this show is one percent of this
audience has ever been to a city council
meeting they never miss the city the
state is their religion and they love
telling people what to do of course I
will I will uh say that of our audience
and guests
we we get some credit because Alex Stein
has certainly been to many
he was here yesterday he does a good job
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time